hi this is dr. Gregory Sadler I'm a
professor of philosophy and the
president and founder of an educational
consulting company called reason IO
where we put philosophy into practice
I've studied and taught philosophy for
over 20 years and I find that many
people run into difficulties reading
classic philosophical texts sometimes
it's the way things are said or how the
text is structured but the concepts
themselves are not always that
complicated and that's where I come in
to help students and lifelong learners
I've been producing longer lecture
videos and posting them to youtube many
viewers say they find them useful what
you're currently watching is part of a
new series of shorter videos each of
them focused on one core concept from an
important philosophical text I hope you
find it useful as well in chapter 16 of
his work on friendship Marcus Tullius
Cicero has Laelius who's presenting his
views say that there's three
fundamentally mistaken views on
friendship that he wants to combat and
each of these can be framed in terms of
something like a rule or a maxim for
decision-making and evaluation it
actually turns out that in this section
he'll throw in a bonus one as well which
we'll get to
at the very end something that Scipio
Laelius his great friend had said was
was fundamentally wrong but he
identifies three at the start and let's
run through these very quickly and then
we'll look at the the issues the first
is that we should have the same feeling
towards the friend as towards ourselves
and this one actually seems on the face
of it a pretty good way of looking at
friendships shouldn't we regard the
friend is just as important as ourselves
a bad friend prioritizes themselves and
their needs and wishes over that of
their friend but Cicero has an argument
here for why that's not the right way to
look at things the second
now we're getting a little bit more
mercenary right our goodwill towards
friends should correspond toward to
their goodwill towards us so we're gonna
look at that in a moment and then the
third one that Cicero has Laelius a is
the worst of them is whatever value a
person places on themselves friends
should place the same value on on that
person and now that also seems like you
know you want to be valued by your
friend to the degree that you value
yourself you love yourself you want your
friend to love you what's wrong with
that well each of these is problematic
for a different reason and so he says
that there's three these are three views
that are usually advanced none of which
I approve so why does he disapprove of
these he says the first one is not true
why how many things we do for our
friends we would never do for ourselves
now of course some people might respond
and say well I mean I I don't do
anything for my friends they do
everything for me well then you're not a
true friend according to Cicero
this is about true friendship genuine
friendship and so you know when you
really do care about somebody there are
quite a few things that you would do for
them that you wouldn't necessarily do
for yourself and he gives some examples
here that I think we can relate to in
our own time quite well he says here we
go at one time we beg and entreat an
unworthy person and another we assail
another too sharply or too loudly rail
upon him things not quite creditable in
our own affairs but exceedingly so in
behalf of friends now this is kind of an
interesting thing to say isn't it so
there's there's things that if it we
were doing it on our own behalf Cicero
was saying it would be unbecoming we we
shouldn't do that sort of thing like you
know complaining or attacking somebody
if we're attacking somebody just on
behalf of ourselves we look like jerks
but if we're doing it on behalf of a
friend who's been in some way in
moondoor insulted somehow that's okay
right and you see this with parents a
lot with their kids there's things that
they'll do you know haranguing coaches
for example so here's a great great case
all right
your kid is playing soccer and they're
on the bench and you feel like they
should get more time you start yelling
at the coach hey put so and so in you're
being unfair now if you were the player
would you be yelling at the coach like
that no because I need people would say
you're selfish but if you do it on
behalf of your friend well then it's
okay I think sister is quite correct
about this another thing that he points
out that is quite interesting this shows
that we go beyond just what we would do
for ourselves having the same sort of
feeling or affection or even care we
allow ourselves to be deprived of things
so that friends can enjoy them we do
things for them that you know take away
from ourselves and sometimes we give
them things that that we ourselves don't
get to enjoy
he says there's numerous occasions when
good people forego or permit themselves
to be deprived of many conveniences
boney multa right in quickest to suis
commode is very bona molted etre wants
to try a patio enter he says right and
why so that our friends may enjoy them
through on tour so that they can in you
know have them and consume them and do
what they're gonna do with them so you
know you open up the the fridge and
there's only one beer left you give the
beer to your friend right instead of
saying well we're gonna split this
exactly down the middle or tough luck
buddy I guess you should have brought a
six-pack or something like that a good
friend will you know do those sorts of
things so Cicero is not saying that we
shouldn't have a similar feeling or
similar care for our friend he's saying
that what's wrong with this is that we
should go
beyond that it shouldn't remain just
similar we should exceed the feeling
that we have for ourselves
let's look at the second one now he says
our goodwill towards friends should
correspond towards their goodwill
towards us and the goodwill here is been
a volunteer which is is an absolute
component of friendship as we've seen
Cicero says take away been a Valencia or
Goodwill and you don't have friendship
left anymore now the question is well
how much goodwill should we have towards
our friends how much this desiring good
for them and and you know this says well
we should desire that to the degree that
they desire for us now here's where it
gets really interesting
he says this limits friendship and here
the translation is to an equal
interchange of services and feelings now
they the Latin for that I've translated
a little bit different here duties and
choices opium is duty but it's also
appropriate action or services sister
action is an entire book which is
usually translated on duties which is
daya fakir right so the things that we
we owe to other people or ought to do
the things that are appropriate for us
to do in relation to them the friendship
is being reduced to that the other word
that's being used here is volume toss
here in the ablative plural voluntati
books and you know this doesn't mean
will in the sense of the Faculty of will
in in this particular text but it does
mean something that we could translate
as Volition's
or we might say choices it's not just
about feelings it's also about what we
want to do and so this reduces
friendship to a mere exchange I give so
that you give or you give so that I give
right
so that's a bit of a problem you know
it's not to say that every friendship
shouldn't have some paying attention to
some monitoring of this and if somebody
doesn't show goodwill to us maybe we
shouldn't be friends with them but we
don't want to say I'm only going to give
you the amount that you give or the
amount that I think that you're giving
the other thing that he says here is
quite nice he says that true friendship
is richer and more abundant than that
divot tea divet tea or and in Latin
richer and then he says a flue ENT or
right and this has the sense of like
overflowing it's not just affluence as
such there's there's a sense in which
it's going to the riches themselves
won't stay in place they will flow out
to to other people and he's got this
beautiful metaphor here he says it
doesn't narrowly scan the reckoning lest
it pay out more than it is received
there need be no fear that some bit of
kindness will be lost that it will
overflow the measure and spill on the
ground or that more that it then as Dew
will be poured into friendships bin so
the if we are measuring and the Cicero
isn't saying that we shouldn't measure
it all here we measure with a generous
measure if a little bit seems to be
falling on the ground that's okay it's
not going to waste we're not you know
you could think of this as responding to
the fear that many people have that if
they give they're not going to get in
return anything so this is not going to
actually be wasted
so our goodwill towards friends should
probably generously exceed the goodwill
that we're assuming on their part or we
should strive to match the goodwill that
they have the third one that again he
says is particularly bad whatever value
a person places on themselves French had
placed some value on them and it's
interesting here that he doesn't go
where we might automatically expect him
to go in in criticism of this what if we
have a friend who thinks too highly of
themselves and wants everybody else to
think highly of them they value
themselves
more important than they are as more
talented as having done greater things
as having contributed in ways that go
beyond what they actually did any of
these sorts of things right or they're
more attractive or they're richer or
they're whittier should we actually like
go along with that and thereby become
essentially flatterers I don't think
sister I would say we should do that but
he doesn't worry about that here
what is he worried about he worries
about the friend who suffers from what
we might nowadays term low self-esteem
that is a view upon the self an
evaluation of the self as having less
worth less value less goodness than it
actually does some people value
themselves as he says too lowly and this
could be for a variety of reasons it
could because they've been bullied and
beaten down or that you know nobody
complements them and tells them that
they're doing a good job it could be
some some trauma in the background or
some other psychological problem be it
whatever it happens to be this person
values themselves too lowly we should
not then say okay well you value
yourself lowly I'm going to value the
same way I'm gonna treat you like the
crap that you think you are instead II
says friends ought to help their friends
in this way they ought to try to elevate
them so very nice way of saying this
here he says it's not the province of a
friend in such a case to have the same
estimate of another that the other has
of himself but rather it's his duty to
strive with all his might to arouse his
friends prostate that has you know
lowered soul and lead it to a livelier
hope and into a better train of thought
so you know space here is the hope and
you talked about Kogi Tati I'm Koka
tottenham meliora a better way of
conceiving of thinking about things
now again Cicero is not saying that
there's
this is a totally off-base idea as such
you know if friends actually are valuing
themselves correctly then there'd be
nothing wrong with valuing your friend
to the same degree that they they value
themselves but in the case of people who
value themselves too lowly we have to be
careful about this we shouldn't take
them at their word because we have to be
good friends to them now I mentioned
there is a little bonus here and in
Cicero mentions Scipio saying that you
know another bad idea about friendship
is we should love as if one time we were
going to hate and he says that this is a
terrible idea
but he doesn't he doesn't include this
in the three so I thought I would just
throw that into sort of a little teaser
at the very end but you know
interestingly these are three ideas
about friendship that were very common
at Cicero's time and I think many people
hold today that he wants to say are
fundamentally mistaken and these are the
reasons why these are off-base
you